he'd come to Mark the return of Neville
shipbuilding to Belfast but Rishi sunak
hopes for a deal with the EU that will
see The Return of devolved government
too
so I've been cleared we don't want to
put a strict deadline on the deals and I
don't want to raise people's
expectations of an imminent breakthrough
but what I can say is I am absolutely
committed to resolving the issues with
the protocol as soon as practically
possible
if the government can't find a way to
reverse this wholeage company fears the
supply chain will collapse but it's
thinking about logistics not politics
politics is an art Logistics is a
science
if the political solution doesn't work
majestically we'll see it very quickly
you say the supply chain would crash
what is the worst case scenario I think
I think the reality is if you removed
the extensions that UK government has
put on the so-called Grace periods
um you applied the rules and fill the
supply chain wouldn't run for more than
48 hours
it was to avoid a land border here
between Northern Ireland and the
Republic that the Sea border came into
operation
and those who Farm these fields and
support the protocol hope this prime
minister will be more pragmatic and not
simply ditch it well Richie comes from
the treasury that was where he spent
years as Chancellor so he fully
understands the economic situation of
the UK right now so he comes with the
knowledge that he needs to do a deal he
he knows the UK economy cannot withstand
a trade war with the EU so I think that
makes it more likely that will be a deal
done on the protocol
given the entrenched positions the
parties hold on the Northern Ireland
protocol someone's going to have to do
some heavy lifting if there's going to
be a truce in this battle over where the
Border should be a compromise that
enables them to restore power sharing in
Northern Ireland
they've been building ships here for two
centuries building peace for two decades
and responsibility for maintaining it
has passed to a man who's been prime
minister for two months
David Blevins Sky News in Belfast